chez jules issia il a des souvenirs dans
les placards et jusque sur les murs sont
petits souvenirs puisque on n'habitait
pas trop en plus du molineux stadium et
on a vu un match là bas c'est sympa elle
revient de cinq mois en angleterre un
semestre à l'étranger qu'elle a pu
effectuer avec le programme erasmus
el al et à l'université devolder hampton
et travailler dans un pub avec son
compagnon tous deux en ont aussi profité
pour voyager à moi je sais que j'avais
peur de partir au début et un conseil
que je peux donner c'est peut-être
n'ayez pas peur parce que vraiment c'est
c'est un truc qu'on va faire dans sa vie
comme une fois comme elle ils sont
chaque année une centaine d'étudiants de
l'université versailles saint quentin en
yvelines a effectué une mobilité avec le
programme erasmus
ruben quant à lui fait partie des
cinquante étudiants étrangers par an à
découvrir le vs q2 ali quand il est
arrivé sur le campus de guyancourt en
septembre l'expérience lui a tellement
plu qu'il a souhaité poursuivre un
semestre supplémentaires c'est une
expérience unique et surtout par la
langue parce que je voudrais c'est le
principal le programme erasmus a fêté
ses 30 ans en 2010 est une collaboration
entre les universités favorisée par
l'union européenne et la mise en place
de bourses facilitant les mobilités pour
les étudiants mais pas seulement on a
aussi tout tous les ans environ 15
étudiants qui profite d'une bourse stage
pour leur mobilité
et puis on à la mobilité des enseignants
chercheurs mais aussi quelle mobilité
administratif par exemple une collègue
de service des bibliothèques est allé
dans une devant une formation à une
université est trop partenaires lu vs qr
ainsi pu nouer de bons contacts avec des
universités à l'international ensemble
elles développent des projets
pédagogiques à la bourse erasmus
s'ajoute une aide de la région
ile-de-france et une aide à la mobilité
internationale sur critères sociaux
l'objectif est de faire profiter de
cette expérience au plus grand nombre
d'étudiants possible il faut être ouvert
à l'étranger au bénéfice de l'éthique en
l'étudiant qui est dans une bonne
université qui est bien accueillie il
progresse dans ses études et le
développe des compétences qu'ils
n'auraient pas développer ici de la même
manière
des études démontrent qu'une mobilité à
l'étranger permet une meilleure
progression dans sa carrière
professionnelle le pôle mobilité de l'ue
vs qu est situé à la maison de
l'étudiant marta pan une quinzaine de
pays sont proposés d'autres partenariats
sont également noué avec des universités
hors europe